so in the end he came to Brussels with a
new brexit deal to sell the British
Prime Minister's claiming the
breakthrough is in everyone's interest
now is the moment for us to get bricks
it done and then together to work on
building our future partnership which I
think can be incredibly positive both
for the UK and for the EU and speaking
alongside Johnson the president of the
European Commission sounded relieved
this is a fair a balanced agreement it
is testament to our commitment to
finding solutions he provides certainty
where budget creates uncertainty
and protects peace and stability on the
people but these anti brexit campaigners
are far from assured they say they're
being forgotten Nicola James is a
British citizen based in the Netherlands
and married to a Dutchman the changes I
wouldn't be able to go back to the UK
with my husband to live in case my
parents needed more help because we
wouldn't of course no one here in
Brussels or in fact anywhere can say
with certainty that this new brexit deal
can become a reality on Saturday it's
set to come before the UK Parliament and
that's where the previous deal came
unstuck on Thursday the leader of the
Opposition signaled his party would vote
against the agreement as it stands we
can't support this deal and will oppose
it in Parliament on Saturday and it also
is unclear if he has the support of his
allies in the DUP or indeed many of his
allies on his own back benches Northern
Ireland's Democratic Unionist Party or
DUP says it's still not happy with the
text it matters because its stance could
determine how hardline brexit errs in
Johnson's own Conservative Party vote so
Britain heads towards the deadline of
the end of this month without a deal in
place the Prime Minister's legally
obliged to seek an extension from
Brussels his office says that's not
going to happen
brexit it would seem is far from
Nadine Baba al Jazeera Brussels